when it comes to oriental rugs Tammi
noir dat can fulfill his customers every
desire his business based in Hamburg's
warehouse district has rugs from India
Pakistan and Iran among them
masterpieces such as a real Persian rug
for 30,000 euros society outsider now
this is silk on silk you can feel how
beautiful and soft it feels this is the
kind of craft that only a master weaver
can produce that takes a long time and
the material itself is also very
expensive for 35 years why dat has dealt
in all kinds of oriental carpets but
sales have slowed since then it started
off as fashionable home decor but by the
end of the 90s prices had fallen they've
only just picked up in the past few
years wha dat hopes for a return of the
80s Persian carpet boom
thus far as zfe under a lot of trucks
came from iran or ships from overseas so
many new hardly had time to take on the
products and they were spread across the
world but Hamburg was really a hub for
the carpets Hamburg wah I need
grieshaber the reputation of a hub in
the oriental rug trade is something
Hamburg wants to keep especially after
the end of economic sanctions on Iran
Germany has been able to import carpets
but paying for the wares was tricky cash
transfers via banks were almost
impossible wholesaler alia Peck she
deals exclusively with Iranians and
hopes now for more support from the
banks of course we're expecting payments
to become easier with the agreement made
at the beginning of this year that'll
make the entire sales process easier
Vardhan dealers are also setting their
sights on the North American market
where the trade embargo effectively
banned importing Persian rugs as a
wholesaler apec she wants to import
carpets from Hamburg into the u.s. and
Canada Vishwa we're talking about 250
million customers that's a huge market
if you can conquer it and I think the
Persian rug has a good shot at that
before the embargo it had significant
market share there and the hope is that
it can successively regain that Jeff
Lewis noted I said user Oh success UAV
that's why couldn't APEC she still has
one worried in post sanctions Iran if
the Iranian economy booms the currency
the rial will strengthen and that'll
make Persian carpets more expensive for
the importers